what is up guys it is Jerry um I'm
trying something slightly new today I
just got out of divergence and we
usually like to do these things if we
can you know usually a day after seeing
them or something like that just because
you know you give the movie a little
time to sit and you know germinate in
your head Ryan and I are gonna actually
sit down and talk about this movie
tomorrow morning but I thought it would
be kind of cool just to do sort of a
first impressions kind of thing to just
give it a try and then see how it
changes when we shoot the actual review
yeah so I just got out of divergent
which is a new film based on a young
adult novel or series of novels or
something like that and it takes place
in this sort of utopian or utopian
future in which everybody in society is
sort of divided up into these factions
there's the warrior class which is the
Dauntless there's the erudite which are
the really smart sort of learned in
folks there's the abdication and I think
they're called or like sort of selfless
and charitable and there are two others
one sort of seemed like it like a
provider like a sort of agricultural
sort of place and I can't even remember
what the other one was a kind of
construction but yeah it takes place in
in this version of the future and become
a certain age everyone goes through this
rite of passage where they take a test
and then they choose this is one of
those you know future utopia dystopia
movies kind of like The Hunger Games or
the host and it's pretty cool I mean the
thing about this movie is there's a lot
of cool stuff in here the tone is good
the cinematography is good it seems to
be directed pretty competently and
there's a lot there are a lot of really
good performances shalane Woodley is
great she has some really gorgeous
moments and for the most part I really
do like the cast their couple
recognizable faces in there Ray
Stevenson has a small part miles teller
as a small part
kate winslet is it a little bit mekhi
phifer pops up for a minute Jai Courtney
is in this movie playing Macklemore when
you see it you will understand most of
the cast is pretty good there are a
couple of supporting characters who are
all over the top but um I did enjoy this
movie and there are certainly a lot of
great scenes the only problems i really
have us are sort of with this with the
script is some of the characters just
end up being types you know it's like
miles teller only really ever shows up
to be a dick and then leave again you
know whereas others actually get some
development and some weight so that's a
little disappointing and I don't know if
this is even the writers fault
specifically but I'm there there are a
few moments where it can't avoid giving
in to young adult novel cliches you'll
know the kind of moments when you see
them certain little lines in there and
certain little things that happen where
you're like okay that's it's for the
kids you know the biggest thing for me
during this movie is there are a number
of times where I feel like the mechanics
of this world haven't fully been thought
out there's just a number of times I
found myself wondering like how did this
society get to this point in first place
like you know I mean it's a cool idea um
though it might be a little bit
oversimplified there are a couple things
that clear up along the way that you'll
sort of understand as time goes by but
the moving never for me anyway fully
figures out how to make this society
entirely believable because forever
believable moment there's an equally
glossed over or underdeveloped moment
but is there some cool action and some
cool ideas they get into some dark
territory which which you know makes me
happy especially in its darker
connotations and it's sort of questions
about these various parts of society at
certain times it seems like it can't
help itself from being a little bit too
heavy-handed with like these people are
evil but like i said the cast is is good
for the most part yeah some cool action
some great visuals uh you know a neat
version of the future if not fully
developed so it's definitely worth
checking out I'm interested to see how
this is gonna feel then you know 20 or
so hours when one Ryan and I actually
sit down and talk about it it's had time
to really sit my head but that's my
first impression I guess so that's about
it for today um yeah if you've seen the
movie or or read the books let me know
your thoughts and until next time you
know comment below like subscribe all
that good stuff if you want to follow us
on the twitters i am reasons to Jeri
Ryan is to Rio ryan right with a go and
there's also the real rejects uh yeah so
until next time cheers folks and talk to
you soon